♪ ♪
>> Shannon: AS WE TOLD YOU
EARLIER THE WEEKENDS MASS
SHOOTINGS HAS RENEWED CALLS FOR
GUN LEGISLATION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TALKED ABOUT GUN
VIOLENCE THIS MORNING.
LET'S DISCUSS THAT WITH A KEY
MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
LINDSEY GRAHAM, CHAIR OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE JOINS US
FROM GREENVILLE, SOUTH CAROLINA.
WELCOME SENATOR.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
I AM HERE AT THE G.O.P.
>> Shannon: WE WILL TRY TO DO
THAT WITH YOU.
I WANT TO GET YOUR REACTION TO
THE WEEKENDS EVENTS AND OF
COURSE AS PREDICTABLE PLENTY OF
REACTION ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
AISLE.
>> NUMBER ONE THE PEOPLE, IT'S A
SLICK AND SENSELESS CRIME AND
THERE IS A COMMON PATTERN IN
MANY OF THESE CASES AND PEOPLE
ARE DISTURBED AND THEY TAKE THE
LAW ON THEIR OWN HANDS AND THEY
ACT OUT AND IT'S TIME FOR US TO
CALL -- CALL THE PRESIDENT NAMES
WILL NOT SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
I AM LOOKING FOR A DEMOCRAT WHO
WORKED WITH AND NOT TO INSULT.
I'M HOPING I CAN FIND SOME
DEMOCRATS THAT WILL WORK WITH ME
STARTING WITH THE IDEA OF
RED FLAG LAWS.
I THINK THESE ORDERS HAVE A LOT
OF HOPE TO SOLVE SOME OF THESE
CASES.
>> Shannon: I WANT TO PUT UP A
MAP NOW, THERE ARE NUMBER OF
STATES THAT HAVE DONE THIS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
OF COURSE THERE ARE ALWAYS
CONCERNS ABOUT DUE PROCESS.
RIGHTS COULD BE VIOLATED BEFORE
PEOPLE HAVE A CHANCE TO MAKE
THEIR SIDE OF THE CASE.
HOW DO YOU THREAD THE NEEDLE?
>> INDIANA WAS ONE OF THE FIRST
STATES TO DO THIS.
HERE'S WHAT WE DO.
THIS WILL NOT BE A FEDERAL LAW,
A GRANT PROGRAM AND TO GET THE
FEDERAL GRANTS YOU HAVE TO HAVE
DUE PROCESS.
THERE HAS TO BE AN IMMINENT
THREAT OF HARM TO ONESELF OR TO
OTHERS BEFORE THE POLICE AND YOU
CAN ONLY BE THE POLICE, YOU HAVE
A HEARING.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE MORE LIKELY
THAN NOT STANDARD, THERE IS AN
IMMINENT THREAT.
SEVEN DAYS LATER YOU HAVE A
FULL-BLOWN HEARING, CLEAR AND
CONVINCING EVIDENCE WHERE THE
GUN OWNER CAN DEFEND THEMSELVES
AND THEY HAVE TO PROVE BY CLEAR
AND CONVINCING EVIDENCE THAT THE
PERSON IS DISTURBED OR DANGER TO
THEMSELVES OR OTHERS AND IF THAT
IS MET THEY CAN SEIZE THE GUNS
AND GIVE THE PERSON THE HELP
THEY NEED.
AND PARKLAND, FLORIDA, 42 VISITS
BY THE COPS AND NO WAY TO STOP
HIM.
HE DID EVERYTHING BUT TAKE AN AD
OUT IN THE PAPER SAYING I WILL
KILL PEOPLE, I WANT TO ENCOURAGE
THESE LAWS AND THAT IS THE
PRESIDENT'S GOAL.
>> Shannon: HE TALKED ABOUT
THAT TODAY, TRYING TO UNIFY AND
MAKE THIS NOT A PARTISAN ISSUE.
THAT HAS BEEN REALLY TOUGH TO
DO.
I WANT TO PLAY SOMETHING FROM
THE FORMER DEMOCRATIC
CONGRESSWOMAN TALKING ABOUT THE
DISCUSSION WITHIN THE CONTEXT
AND HE SAID IT'S A DOMESTIC
ISSUE WE HAVE TO LOOK AT AND HE
IS NOT BUYING WITH THE PRESIDENT
WAS SELLING TODAY.
>> WE NEED A WAR, A WAR ON
TERRORISM HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA TO
ERADICATE.
THE FIRST THING WE NEED TO DO IS
THE PRESIDENT OF UNITED STATES
HAS TO STOP.
THEY HAVE TO STOP IGNITING THE
FLAMES OF HATRED AND BIGOTRY AND
DIVISION IN THIS COUNTRY.
I DON'T BELIEVE ANY OF WHAT YOU
SAID TODAY.
>> Shannon: WHERE'S THE
BIPARTISAN ACT?
>> WE ARE GETTING CLOSE WE WILL
GO BY THE WHITE HOUSE AND WE
TALK TO GOD OWNING GROUPS OF THE
COPS
AND WE ARE TRYING TO COME UP
WITH A SERIOUS SOLUTION TO A
SERIOUS PROBLEM.
WE ARE TRYING TO EMPOWER POLICE
OFFICERS TO DO SOMETHING BEFORE
IT IS TOO LATE WITH PLENTY OF
DUE PROCESS.
WE ARE NOT TRYING TO TAKE
ANYBODY'S GUNS AWAY FROM THEM.
WE ARE TRYING TO GET THE GUNS
OUT OF THE HANDS OF PEOPLE WHO
ARE DANGEROUS YOU MAY KILL
THEMSELVES OR SOMEBODY ELSE.
WE'RE TRYING TO SHUT DOWN THESE
SOCIAL MEDIA SITES AND FIND
SOLUTIONS AND FOR THE LAST
24 HOURS IT'S BEEN PRETTY
DISAPPOINTING TO HEAR ALL THE
RHETORIC DIRECTED AT
PRESIDENT TROUT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT THE
PROBLEM
HERE.
THE CONGRESS HAS BEEN TALKING
AND IT'S TIME TO ACT AND IF WE
CAN COME UP WITH A PACKAGE THAT
HAS PROTECTIONS FOR THE GUN
OWNER BUT ALLOWS THE COP TO DO
SOMETHING, I HOPE WE CAN GET A
VOTE.
>> Shannon: I WANT TO ASK YOU
ABOUT SOME FOREIGN POLICY
ISSUES.
THE PRESIDENT TALKING ABOUT THAT
HE CAMPAIGNED ON BRINGING OUR
TROOPS HOME FROM A NUMBER OF
CONFLICTS AROUND THE WORLD AND
HE IS NOT TALKING ABOUT
AFGHANISTAN.
HERE'S WHAT HE SAID ABOUT
BRINGING THOSE FOLKS HOME.
>> LEE ABOUT THEIR 19 YEARS.
LET'S PUT IT THIS WAY, WE ARE
MORE POLICEMEN THAN EVERYTHING
ELSE AND THAT'S NOT FOR OUR
SOLDIERS.
WE COULD WIN THE WAR IN
AFGHANISTAN AND LESS THAN A
WEEK, BUT I'M NOT LOOKING TO
KILL A 10 MILLION PEOPLE AND I'M
NOT TALKING NUCLEAR.
>> Shannon: WHAT ARE YOUR
CONCERNS ABOUT BRINGING EVERYONE
HOME?
>> EVERY COMMANDER OF DOC TO
COME OF THE COMMUNITY SAYS THAT
AL QAEDA AND ISIS ARE REEMERGING
AND IF WE WITHDRAW ALL OF OUR
FORCES THEY CAN HIT US IN THE
REGION AND HERE AT HOME.
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT THEY TOLD
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
IT'S NOT RIGHT TO LEAVE.
IF WE HAD A RESIDUAL FORCE AND I
ROCK THERE WOULD BE NO ISIS THEY
HAVE NOW MOVED TO AFGHANISTAN.
MY IDEA THAT A SMALL FORCE THAT
WILL PROTECT THE AMERICAN HOME
LAND FROM ANOTHER 9/11, IT'S NOT
ME JUST SAYING THAT IT'S THE
COMMANDER, PRESIDENT TRAUB HAS
DONE A GREAT JOB
OF REBUILDING THE MILITARY.
WE HAVE OUR FOOT ON THEIR
THROATS AND IF WE PULL ALL OF
OUR TROOPS OUT IT WOULD BE A
MATTER OF TIME TILL THEY
REGENERATE.
THE GOOD NEWS IS A VERY SMALL
COUNTERTERRORISM FORCE IS AN
INSURANCE POLICY AGAINST ANOTHER
9/11 AND I HOPE THE
PRESIDENT WILL SEE IT THAT WAY
AND FOLLOW THE ADVICE OF HIS
COMMANDERS AND IF HE GETS IN A
DEBATE WITH JOE BIDEN, AREN'T
YOU THE GUY THAT GAVE US ISIS?
THAT TOLD -- WE ARE GETTING OUT?
DON'T GO DOWN THE JOE BIDEN
BARACK OBAMA ROAD WHEN IT COMES
TO AFGHANISTAN.
THIS IS WHERE THE WHOLE THING
STARTED AND WE HAVE TO GET
AFGHANISTAN.
THE GOOD NEWS, WITH A FEW
THOUSAND COUNTERTERRORISM FORCES
WE CAN PROTECT AMERICA FOR A